this has de brought the Thunder with
fallout 4 at e3 last year but there was
still a hell of a lot to get excited
about in this year's conference here's
the rapper that has to kick off their
conference in style with the first
gameplay trailer for quake champions by
its software after well and truly
delivering with the ass-kicking heavy
metal vibe of doom the devs are now
ready to talk about quake champions the
competitive arena shoot of a pc is set
to run at 120 hertz with unlocked frame
rates and it will feature caste of
warriors with different attributes the
publisher then detailed to the upcoming
card game Elder Scrolls Legend and
showed up all the new updates and deals
see that are on their way to fallout 4
and fallout shelter this has to follow
that up by revealing that Skyrim is
indeed being remastered for Xbox one and
ps4 3 monster is called the special
edition and will feature updated
graphics effects and the inclusion of
mods after that the buzz was all about
Arkane Studios prey which is returning
from the grave as a gorgeous-looking
psychological thriller 4 ps4 xbox one
and pc the game takes place in the year
2032 and centers around the dude named
Morgan who seems like he's about to have
a really bad time a bunch of new
multiplayer content was revealed for
doom and in what is certainly the
coolest possible addition they could
have gone for Dark Brotherhood dlc was
announced for the Elder Scrolls online
they're also introducing an update
called one Tamriel which lets you
explore the world freely without the
restrictions of your level quests or
alliances EA didn't have much to say
about VR but Bethesda revealed that
fallout 4 and doom will be getting
virtual reality editions slap for the
launch in 2017 for the HTC vive Bethesda
close out the show with a look at
dishonour to developed by Arkane Studios
the game is set 15 years after the
events of the first dishonored this time
both corvo attano and Emily called w'en
artfully voice and will have their own
perspectives on the series of events as
unfold as if all that wasn't enough we
were also treated to a length the
gameplay demo which showed off combat
scenarios and several of Emily's
supernatural abilities dishonor to is
due out on November 11 of this year we
should let me know which of Bethesda's
announcements you're excited for and
check back to gamespot for all the
latest on everything a3 throughout the
week